working as a doctor last year of medical
school I'm having to move in
[Music]
white taking as much food as possible
with me so I can survive for a
[Music]
bath w
so I'm moving back to University for my
final year of medical school so this
time next year I'll be working as a
doctor if everything goes to plan which
is mad I really don't want to stop
studying and get into the real adulthood
but for now I'm going to romanticize
this train journey and probably get a
little anxious about this upcoming
educational
[Music]
year thanks for picking me up no worries
at all how does it feel to be back in
accident it
feels yeah cuz you get copyrighted yeah
it feels good for some reason I'm
excited to be back I don't know why you
were here last year as well it's just
excitement of you know you're in control
of your life I mean when you're in a
family house it's less independent even
though my family isn't restrictive but
it still feels less independent yeah it
feels like you can't really get anything
done you can't really make your own
plans you're in like a brain flog or a
slump hold on there's no traffic lights
here yeah that's
weird you actually got so much better in
driving since I last saw you thank you I
was wondering if you're going to say
that so I'm GL
thought about the
situation we've arrived at the
destination now I'm waiting for James so
that I can move into the room but I'm
hungry where can I put these any
[Music]
F let's get this done James let's move
in I'm so sleepy this is the room that
James has kindly given me you can't show
that as long as I can access the bed I'm
fine yeah I just want to be able to
sleep in this room and that's all what
about charging your phone I'm charging
my
phone there might be a sucker down there
but going get to it there is one here
I'm not if we can move the bed a little
bit
wait oh nice this will be fine honestly
as long as I like move it a little bit I
can sleep tilted it's fine yeah yeah
just don't wake up
[Music]
like I'm going to take off my socks
because they're dirty I don't want to
put it in my make sure what you sensor
that for your video cuz people like sell
them and people are like really creepy
what feet pictures yeah
yeah oh my God
so good morning in an hour I have my
induction starting or Americans call it
orientation and this is the room I'll be
staying in for the next 2 days I'm
staying at my friend's house until my
landlord lets me into my actual house so
I'm having to move in twice because our
House's tennis agreement starts in
September because most University
degrees start later on but of course
finally Medics are an exception to that
we start almost a month before everyone
else
does
just finished with the lectures and
picked up some letters now we're going
to a cafe to do the online
[Music]
training all of my friends left the cafe
2 hours ago it's just been me studying
by myself but finally I finished all the
online training now I can go home or
James's home to have some food that my
mom cooked for
me hi hi welcome back how's the cafe
I've done work so that was good yeah
what have you been doing I was talking
to one of my friends which friend oh the
friend yeah I got stuff to tell you
about
[Music]
okay is
it all the online training how do you do
it like how do you access it I'll show
it to you I didn't know so like love
showed me and this one and then now I'm
going to meet my ex placement partner
when I was in third year of medical
school I'm so
excited hello
hi good
[Music]
morning
today is the big day we're moving into
my actual house yay but I don't know how
that's going to happen because we have
the busy day schedule we start at 9:00
and finish at 5 but I'm hoping we'll be
able to leave the last session early
because it's named the pizza session So
the plan is getting the free pizza and
leaving but now I just want to go on top
of some work before I start the day
during the induction week we get so many
emails I just want to go through all of
them to make sure I'm not missing
anything and figure out what I need to
do about
[Music]
them the time reader going home to have
breakfast and grab my glasses so I can
see the
[Music]
lectures good morning good morning how
are you feeling about today Jam it's
going to be a long day I hope it's
somewhat useful but some stuff that we
don't even know what it is like that
Development Day thing yeah it says pizza
so I'm hoping it's just pizza how come
you were up at 6:00 a.m. but we're still
late well is it my fault I think it
is update apparently it doesn't stop at
Pizza Station we still have more stuff
this development day until 5: so I won't
be able to move in oh really yeah I mean
no I will be able to move in but L yeah
not on time basically and this guy's
still eating his pizza because he's a
very slow eater no I don't eat when I'm
talking that's why and I was chatting
with Pablo and a girl but I and a girl
do you want that on YouTube a girl that
I met in my interview in 2017 okay okay
sorry it's my bad for understanding it
in a different way yeah yeah that
[Applause]
is
sorry thank
you we're home I just need to figure out
how to carry this really heavy suitcase
all the way up to my room which is three
floors up I think I'll just have to take
stuff out carry upstairs until it's
light
[Music]
enough I think it's light enough for me
to carry
now I'm back in my room wo
nice I took a break from unpacking
talking about
the try the T to how are you guys
feeling about being back at Uni I'm
excited you look very excited I am
looking forward okay I'm excited for
placement less excited about the
workload but with time we'll get used to
it it's going to be our last year of
medical school last time we purch these
students and take advantage of it oh J
don't remind me we're going to have to
do lots of clubs societies hang out with
loads of people I'm excited for the
course as well there's going to be a lot
to learn so that we're actually
competent competent doctors
yeah8
[Applause]
[Music]
please I was just in the middle of
unpacking my scrubs and stethoscope and
I realized I'm to start packing again
because tomorrow I have my Hospital
placement and the hospital I'm allocated
to is in another town which is around 2
hours away from my medical school and
I'll be staying there for the next 6
weeks commuting is just part of a
medical student lifestyle in the UK so
I'll see you there
bye